[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMJAD MASAD: Today I want to
talk about how we brought--
what everyone is
hearing about today
with serverless, how we brought
that model to cloud IDEs.
And, essentially, we
didn't do it on purpose.
We almost did it accidentally.
So what Repl.it is, before I get
into the serverless stuff, is--
our mission is to bring
programming to more people.
We want to be able to support
any device, any computer
out there.
Anyone who has a computer
should be able to code.
Coding should be as easy
as opening a new tab.
That's sort of like what we do.
And from there we kind of get
progressively more advanced.
And I'll show you
some of the stuff
that you can do
with the platform.
So it is essentially
an online IDE
for more than 50
programming languages.
Zero setup, you can
just start immediately.
And it's becoming
also a platform
for hosting code
and hosting apps.
And on top of that, we have a
very friendly, open community
for people who are getting
started with programming,
and even advanced
programmers as well.
So I'll give a quick demo.
So the getting
started experience
is that you basically pick
a programming language.
I'm just going to
pick Node.js here.
You name it.
So let's say, devzone.
Create a REPL.
And you're immediately booted up
with an interactive programming
environment.
You see a big, green Run button.
And that kind of invites you
to just start coding and start
doing something.
On the right, we have the REPL.
And you can sort of--
it's like an interactive REPL.
You can define variables.
You can console.log
variables, and do anything
you can do with a REPL.
But it gets a little bit
more interesting when, say,
you want to require--
let's say you copied some
code from the internet
and had the library Lodash.
Repl.it will
automatically detect that
and will start
installing the package.
So that's something
we do to just make
programming a lot easier.
And so I can use any--
you immediately get really
good autocomplete as well.
So you don't have to set up
any LSP or anything like that,
we just do it for you.
And I can run that.
Where it gets really
interesting is
that let's say I want
to get a server running.
So I can do something
like import Express JS.
So I can go to our package
manager and import Express.
Let me just zoom that in.
The moment I hit Add, it will
create a package.json for me
and will start
installing Express.
By the time I go
back to the editor,
Express is already
available for me.
I can require that.
I can start Express app.
I have an app.
And say on root, we're going
to just say "Hello, world."
And someone shout a port for me.
Any port.
8080, I heard.
So any port would work.
The IDE will detect that you're
trying to do web programming
and will open up a web view.
And now we have a website
hosted at devzone.amasad.repl.
And it just-- it's
cut off on your side
here but it just
says, "Hello, world."
And that's, like,
hosted forever.
You can come back
to it any time.
I could also open a shell.
And I could inspect my
files from the shell.
And now you might
be starting to think
that this is running on a
VM, that there's like a VM
powering this on
the back end and you
can do whatever you want on it.
However, it's not.
What we do, all of this
is running in a container.
I'm going to just use Chrome
DevTools to put it offline.
So I'm going to put it offline.
It stopped loading.
Now put it online again.
Everything went back
to the same state.
And what has
happened there is we
either spun down the
container, or if we spun down
the container then we're going
to start a new container,
we're going to bring
all the existing state,
and there's going to be
sort of a negotiation
protocol between the
IDE and the container.
Like, here's my state.
I have a shell open.
I have a window that I'm
programming a website open.
And we reconstruct the state
in a matter of milliseconds.
We copy the files
into the container
and we spin everything back up.
And this use case is not
only viable for, like,
web programming.
You could also do native
application programming.
So here's like the
famous pygame--
the famous sort of
pygame game framework.
And I'm just going to run
one of their examples.
And we're going to
stream down VNC and start
playing games in the browser.
And let me go back to
the presentation now.
So let me walk you through
a little bit of history
of how we built this.
And then I'll go into a little
bit more detail on the back end
and how we built our, like,
fake VM via serverless model.
So what we want is we want a
sandbox to execute code in.
We want to execute unsafe code
that was given by our users.
And it needs to have
access to system resources.
Anything that you can do beyond
the simple case of practicing
a program, you have to
actually use system resources.
Network, file system, etc.
It should work everywhere.
Should be cross-browser.
And it should load fast, and
should be extremely cheap.
Right now, today, Repl.it
has more than a million
monthly active programmers
writing code on our platform.
If we were to give a VM to
everyone, like, say, Google
Shell or some of these
VMs with an online editor,
it's going to be
very, very costly.
And most of our users
don't have the money
to actually pay for that.
So our first pass,
we're like, OK.
Since we want this cheap,
what we're going to do
is we're going to actually
compile all the languages
to JavaScript.
We're going to use
Wasm.js and we're
going to emulate this
[INAUDIBLE] layer on the client
to make it work on your browser.
We ran into a lot of problems.
It had a huge bundle size.
We had a 15 megabyte
JavaScript bundle
for like Python and all the
kind of Unix interfaces.
And you know if you're
someone with a Chromebook
somewhere with a
really bad connection
and you're downloading
this much JavaScript,
you're going to run out
of memory just trying
to parse the JavaScript.
And it also didn't have access
to real system resources,
no matter how much
we tried to fake it.
So now we moved it
to the back end.
But that was two--
that was almost three years ago.
And serverless wasn't
really a thing.
Like, it started
becoming a thing,
but it wasn't even on our minds.
So we had to make something
that was cheap enough
that we could run.
So it should feel like a VM.
But a VM is actually
very costly, right?
So what we did, we're like,
all right, we're gonna do it,
we're going to make it run
on on-demand containers.
Containers should be ephemeral.
Any time we take out
a set of computing--
anytime you're idle
in the IDE we should
be able to take your
container from you
and only bring it back when
you're actually executing code
or you're doing
something in the IDE.
It shouldn't run on preemptable
Google Compute Engine or AWS
spot instances.
Basically you want to run
it as cheaply as possible.
Preemptable compute
is 80% cheaper.
So how do we do that?
And again, it's this
ephemeral model.
It should have
reproducible state.
So let's say we're on
GCP preemptable They
take one of our
instances and your coding
on that in a container
inside that instances.
We should be able to
reconstruct the state
and should not basically
feel that there was a change.
And it should scale up and
down according to demand.
So here's the architecture
that we came up with.
So we started building
this before Kubernetes was
the phenomena that it is today.
Maybe if we built it today,
we'd start with Kubernetes.
But when we started,
we're like, OK,
we're going to have these
virtual machine instances.
Inside them we're
going to have Docker.
We wrote our own container
manager orchestration system.
We're going to have
the files live on GCS.
We're going to have some kind
of state and redis and etcd.
And we're going to have
a Docker image registry.
And then we're going to have a
proxy that actually, whenever
a request comes in,
finds the container
and connects you to
the right container.
So when we start a REPL, which
is what we call a project,
a REPL is basically a
union of a Docker image,
a GCS state in terms of files,
and some kind of internal state
about who the user is,
and authorizations,
and what collaborators
they have,
and different things like that.
So that's kind of the high level
over overview of our back end.
To dig deep a little
bit onto the components,
Conman is our container manager.
You can think of it as something
like Kubernetes or Docker
Swarm.
It figures out what needs to
run, where it needs to run,
and creates the containers
for those things to run.
Pid1 is a program that we
inject into the container.
And pid1 is basically the
inits program that we use.
Pid1 knows how to
talk our protocol.
And it's responsible for
reproducing the state when
you get a new container.
So when you get a
new container, we
inject this program at
runtime that we call pid1.
It gets run.
And now it's negotiating
the state with the client
in order to reproduce it
to the best of its ability.
And then Container
Registry, we like
to support a lot of languages,
a lot of environments.
So for every environment
we create a new container.
And we're constantly
updating these containers.
Fixing bugs, releasing
security issues.
So we use Google Container
Registry to be able to do that.
And storage, that was like a no
brainer to use GCS for storage.
For the proxy, you saw me how
when I started a web server,
it just understood that I want
to serve some external traffic.
And what we do is we
add some state or redis,
and then our proxy knows
where to send the traffic.
We get a cert from
Let's Encrypt,
and we give you
HTTPS on the fly.
And, finally, the state
where I mentioned it,
it lives on redis
and the other places.
[MUSIC PLAYING]